It's possible to get through this
program with relatively little
interaction with your classmates.
Most classes don't require forum
participation, few classes have group
projects, and you don't have to get
involved with the social communities.
But we really recommend
you do these things.
One of the biggest assets of this
program is the students themselves.
You'll be in classes with scientists,
executives, influential
people from around the world,
and they'll have unique insights and
perspectives into your work.
So while you're in this program,
take advantage of this resource.
Interact on the forums, interact on
the social communities, get to know your
classmates..h And take advantage of
access to this very unique student body.